you got to like uh obviously you know
the wilding out thing is a big deal
first of all i feel like nick cannon
doesn't get enough flowers in general
just for like
wilding out and the
careers that have helped start and um
just
i look up to nick cannon i think he's an
incredible businessman incredible
creative but um
uh how how did that initially happen um
basically uh
i was going through like a bad
relationship like i said all the time
um and i was asking god for a sign when
i got on my instagram i seen that kind
of like yo it's your boy nick can who
y'all want to see on water or not yeah
yeah
so um i got up and i took the last money
i had went to the slaughter and got me a
water night hoodie and i started doing
skits every day
and um
it's like the the view started to go up
on it um then people were like i'm gonna
get you i'm gonna link you when they can
and no no never did it dj head called me
like hey you talked to nick i was like
nah i talked to nick he like all right
connected the dots put nick on the phone
and nick was like hey um
people been telling me about your [ __ ] i
just never watched it um but i can't
guarantee you're gonna make my show but
i can give you an audition and i was
like bro don't guarantee me [ __ ] give me
the audition and i'll show you why
because i don't believe in
nobody just giving me something like
that just here yeah remember you'd
rather earn it because i want to know
the importance of
having this
versus me having it and not knowing the
importance of it you know i'm saying i i
want to i want to work my way to to
understand why i got this so um they was
like all right do an audition tape like
what you mean do an audition tape like i
don't got to come to y'all they're like
nah make your own i was like [ __ ] went
to the barber shop
set it up like the water and i had the
tables had the chairs i had the water
now girls and i played every game and i
did all that and i put in the video and
they didn't hit me back so i was like oh
my [ __ ] sucked and then they called me
like
i think like a week or so before my
birthday and was like we want to fly you
to atlanta and um you know go to
workshop and that's how that happened
because my hard work head you know what
i'm saying ali hooping that [ __ ] because
i deserved it not because he just doing
a favor but i deserved it and
the rest was history as i got there